yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing random and B yeah somehow it
screwed up my recording setup so it
might look slightly different unusual
maybe just very slightly but I had to
just set up something again that I well
whatever
had to lead it it's sometimes we had the
software or the user using the software
okay so we call a scotch for nights mh6
yeah maybe e5 immediately is correct I'm
not sure okay so I'm a bit too tempted
to him to play e5 I think I'm going to
do it if he grabs it
I have Bishop a3 which should always
give me a good compensation it basically
has to take I mean night yeah I mean
it's not like it loses but that loads
that doesn't look good so I can take
ecigs even and then check on age 5 or or
or else yeah couple of interesting long
as possible
[Music]
even just c4 is good can also take and
check on g6 definitely also dangerous
but probably not not winning I mean this
allows Bishop allows me to play Bishop
to b2 if he goes a night before I will
take on e6 that is not and then Bishop
g6 that I cannot believe that he can
stand the knight on before I think
Knight f6 has to be played now or maybe
not c7 you needed a Fender badly that
before looks wrong okay so now twin to
f3 is one idea and a simple one I'm just
threatening to take the pawn and if he
really really really wants to go keep it
with Queen d7 Queen g3 looks terrible
for black you cannot cancel short now
you have to probably castle now
even though then Queen to g3 is pretty
awful
yeah Queen g3 is stronger than taking c6
actually
yeah but it doesn't help you know just
if he cancels I can take h6 and on top
of everything I have ideas like Bishop
III Bishop f4 and so on not even not
even material down for this fantastic
position long or Queen's Queen side
queenside castling
yes c5 looks very standard opening
opening everything up looks like the
right choice
okay so Bishop f4 potentially taking and
then Bishop e6 but probably I want you
to go look B one first
yeah rupee one threatens Bishop c7 it's
a complete complete disaster
Bishop takes Queen takes Bishop a6 check
King d7 rupee seven as a threat
you know it takes hm there are many ways
to win even just through k1 but we would
win no move
yeah we came in I'm winning winning the
house don't need more than that
you win the Queen that's enough
Queen take special basics checking the
seven rupee seven and resigns probably I
can also trade and play rugby seven the
setup mate don't be seven looking c8
look F seven check can be a derby one
check check check
I don't see a mate okay then let's win
the Queen Oh could have checked on d6
and then it's just not a playable
opening you have to take on e5 sorry
which will be also very dangerous but
probably not an immediate maid or on
like maybe this say you can still fight
it's just so terrible that you cannot
get the King out of the heart of the
middle of the board
maybe e5 is even stronger I wasn't
entirely certain now that now I see it
is much stronger yeah I mean the engine
shows it but it's also here I [ __ ] I
didn't see that this is a tact
so that night X isn't even a move I can
simply take on B form that means if v is
just yeah end of game basically
oh it's Kim Castle you know yeah there
is never never this yeah and it's bet
better than but yeah and this this you
simply cannot stand it's just too too
bad c4 is one good move from I don't
think I should take there yet that is
probably good compensation something
like this I know but it's not convincing
m-my pieces don't coordinate the engine
actually hates this sacrifice and it's
not necessary can just attack without
giving up anything yeah him if he
castles I'm not even taking c6 I'm going
Queen g3 this is stronger threatening
this and yeah something
something and this is a complete
catastrophe
okay Queen to d7 Queen g3 and yeah c5
not the only move but it simply opens up
everything rupees six given by the
engine didn't see this idea just wonder
ah okay that's actually quite nice I
didn't see that at all I have this one
here right that that wins everything
yeah okay but I do p1 this is just it's
just too much and he I was briefly
thinking if this is a mate maybe but I
couldn't find it I'm sorry
I mean Queen c7 I didn't see a mate
thought maybe there is a checkmate but
it doesn't seem to be something
immediate you can I can take here I can
check but here I didn't see a mate you
can of course win win everything but
it's not a mate and this wins the Queen
and therefore is okay and here Queen d6
is stronger had immediate made yeah but
okay winning the queen is fine enough
black in this opening should play with
d5 castle in d5 or d5 immediately you
can play with d6 like this is a playable
line I think it's fairly risky but it is
certainly not not terrible or anything
but the way he did it
that's too much too much I'm gonna tack
for white yeah thanks a lot for watching